I've teased this story in the past and I've
said that once enough time has passed, I will
tell the story.
And this relates to, you know, we often talk
about the grift of those who find a particular
right wing position that may not even really
be their opinion, or they get pulled in by
audience capture because it's profitable and
they become enlightened to the right.
And this applies to cultural critic and arbiter
of big ideas.
Dave Rubin, who around 40 years of age, I
guess, realized that all of his political
positions were wrong and he became a right
winger.
Candice Owens is another one who has staked
out a very profitable position within the
American right.
And from much of what we know, these were
politics that she sort of fabricated and found
once she determined that they're profitable.
I had a lunch meeting years ago and this person
now has moved on.
So like it's now been long enough that it
wouldn't be identifiable.
This went on right around the time that Dave
Rubin was having his political awakening.
I had lunch with a I would call them.
They they weren't they were sort of like a
radio executive, but not for a particular
station.
They was just a very well-connected person
that knew everybody had, you know, Clear Channel,
all these different places.
And they could they could get jobs.
They could say to a program director, put
this person on, give them, you know, give
them an hour a day on twenty five of your
stations or whatever, how to lunch with them.
And they said to me, listen, what you're doing
is is interesting.
It's fine.
You know, my show is much smaller at the time,
but the right is far more well funded.
And what I'm wondering is, would you for X
amount of dollars become a conservative and
do conservative radio?
Like, how much do you how much is this about
your politics versus how much of this is about
money and and business?
Because I think that you're good.
But the left just this was when online was
far less dominant and terrestrial radio was
still the thing.
The left just doesn't do well on talk radio.
The right does.
And, you know, I could get you a job making
X if you were to do right wing radio and somehow
shift to the right.
At the time, X number of dollars was about
three times what I was making.
And I said, no, I, I, I couldn't live with
myself.
I'm not playing a character here.
And we now know, of course, that there are
many people in media who do play characters.
I think that they tend to be more on the right
than on the left.
I've never personally met anyone who does
left wing media, who's playing a character.
I've met people on the right who certainly
are.
And I said no.
And it was I don't say it was shocking.
Like I had a sense that this stuff went on.
But for me, this has never been I'm an actor
playing the role of a leftist.
As many of you know, sometimes I come across
on an opinion that some in my audience don't
like.
It's not a calculated character for clicks.
I'm just giving you my views at the time as
best as I can kind of present them.
Now, do I regret not going with it and tripling
my income?
No, I don't.
I mean, now now what I'm doing now is far
more lucrative than that would have been.
Remember, this was some time ago, but this
stuff really does exist now.
It doesn't tell us anything definitive about
any particular person.
You know, whether it's Dave Rubin or Candice
Owens, there's questions like as Alex Jones
playing a character or not.
What about, you know, who it really it's not
about that.
Obviously, most of us realize that this kind
of grifting exists, but it's not an exaggeration
to say that it can be profitable.
I mean, the conversation I had was literally
I will call program directors and say we want
to set David up with a slow transition out
of the left into kind of like they weren't
saying, I need the.
Become Alex Jones, but become like a center
right type of guy, and I could have a very
profitable show, they were even talking about,
you know, bring your producers, we can get
them all hired.
So it exists.
And now the question is, who in media has
accepted that type of offer?
Who in media is merely playing a character?
We know certainly about about some folks and
not about others.
So that's the story.
I'm not going to say who it was that was offering
me this.
They were a very serious person.
The meeting was, you know, in a very serious
place in New York City.
And needless to say, it was not for me, it
was the right decision.
I'm perfectly I'm thrilled that I made the
right decision.
I'm thrilled morally.
I'm thrilled financially.
But who has accepted those sort of deals with
the devil?
I think that it's a very interesting question